The Joe Rogan Experience I mean I can
sort of understand that in a sense of
like I'm not an adrenaline junkie like I
don't go for skydives or you know any of
that stuff it doesn't drive me but that
thrill and rush I get of you know
darting a bear or working with a lion or
doing you know swimming with an anaconda
like that fuels me for weeks like I I
like I get getting Goosebumps thinking
about some of them right now because I
get so excited by and it's not just for
a personal rush but rather you know
we're doing it for work or whatever but
those moments stick with me forever and
I I sort of get that but not like I'm
just gonna risk my life over this climb
or whatever you know so what are you
doing on giant anacondas like because
there's always been this thing about
enormous anaconds that live in the
rainforest so yeah there's fascinating
so I love anacondas I believe and I've
got a colleague Brian fry um in
Australia actually and he he has a
similar belief that there are 30-foot
anacondas now 30s a big anaconda but
you're talking about those mysterious
like 1500 Footers Okay so
take out the Amazon and take out
anacondas for a second okay all right
think about where all the largest snakes
are in the world Florida well now yes
but
um you know we've got all these wet
tropical environments that have that
house these huge stakes in Indonesia you
have articulated pythons you have
Burmese pythons you have African rock
pythons Indian rock pythons anacondas
all these big snakes yeah the only place
that has a wet tropical humid high
density of prey environment that doesn't
have a massive snake is the Congo
central Africa now interesting Stay With
Me
these that area is home to some African
rock bite and stuff but not big monster
anaconda size ones right but during
World War II there was a colonel who
flew over there and this was a
well-respected colonel I'm sure Jamie
you'll be able to find this very quickly
a well-respected like I forget he had
like his wings or his his patch of Honor
or whatever like very distinguished who
him and his two passengers in the plane
both reported a hundred foot long snake
they flew over at once they're like wait
a minute what is that they were they
were Dutch Belgium in the Congo
um they flew over at once went what is
that and flew over it two more times to
verify it and got so low to the ground
that they said the snake struck at the
airplane and all three people the pilot
this well-respected Colonel and the two
passengers had the exact same story of
this giant snake in central Africa
interesting yeah and yet no big snake
has ever been proven from there but it's
also a very poorly biologically explored
area and most of the time when these
animals get this big snakes or otherwise
they're in very low yeah here's the
picture they took a photo of it they did
yeah they did
um they're in very low densities so
hmm that's the real photo over on the
left there what do they think it was
they thought it was a giant snake a 50
foot long so that's the photo right
there I believe so
um but the story is fascinating of these
kernels they don't know like what kind
of snake they don't know if it was a
condor python or it would be an
undescribed species because the only
snake there the African rock python
doesn't get that big what is the biggest
snake that we know oh it says it
measured approximately 50 feet in length
saw brown green with a white belly has a
triangle shaped jaw and a head three by
two feet oh my God three foot heads the
photo was later analyzed and verified to
be genuine van leerd uh claims that is
that how you say his name I'm not sure
but that was that was the colonel Remy
van lier as he flew lower for a closer
inspection the snake rose up
approximately 10 feet giving a warning
that it would have attacked a helicopter
if it had been within striking range but
imagine flying over and having a snake
sort of lunge at a helicopter a three
foot Snakehead Jesus so rice Jamie do
you mind going to my Instagram swallow
you alive dude look at this one I posted
a picture day before yesterday this is
18 feet and look at the size of it
compared to me and how scary the snake
is
um now to think of yeah like you said
two by like you're like a you're like an
Eminem to a snake that's a Tic Tac you
want them chocolate covered almonds that
are so good for you yeah whoa look at
the size of that thing that's an
18-footer and look it out granted it's
not three foot by two foot head but
still that thing you know what's the
weight on something like that I was over
200 it broke our scale wow yeah it was
over 200 pounds wow Indonesian villagers
claim to have captured a python that is
almost 49 feet long and weighs nearly
990 pounds I I've seen this it's not
there's no it's not verified at all like
do they have an image of it
um this might be the one that's on the
track actor no it's not there's a fake
one on a tractor that it's fake floated
around well it's just very forced
perspective it's like a wide angle lens
and the snake is right in front but it
looks massive but this is NBC this is
NBC News let's see if it has uh images
this sucker
so these are all like reticks and you
know there's there are big snakes out
there look at the size of that goddamn
thing yeah Jesus
so what is the biggest snake is it a
python the biggest snake that we know of
so the heaviest is the reticulated
python look at the size of that thing
yeah how big is that that's big that's
probably it's probably 20-ish so there's
quite a lot of 20-foot snakes out there
and then there's a couple 21 22s but
that's it and so there's all these
rumors of 30-foot snakes and 40-foot
snakes and blah blah and there's nothing
that's been verified outside of one skin
I believe
I want to say from Indonesia that is
like but skin stretch that says it turns
out to be a tall tale it says when uh
recreation park in Indonesia put a huge
reticulated python on show last week
Keepers insisted to report as it was 49
feet long make it the longest ever
caught but that the fine turned out to
be a tall tale yeah so how big was it
exactly I bet it was 20-ish 21 there it
is yeah 21 feet still yeah crazy it's a
big snake man but not 50 not 50. I have
no idea why the snake has shrunk said
one keeper when asked about discrepancy
as the snake lounged on a tree branch
inside the cave but things do shrivel up
when you catch them you know like fish
do like when you catch them fish yeah
well definitely when you tell people
about it but
yeah
I went fishing here in Austin this
morning oh did you really right downtown
literally right in front of the Google
building Lady Bird Lake yeah it was
awesome yeah it's a great little spot
yeah yeah really fun right in front of
the Google building right in front of it
yeah yeah
um so the biggest in the world is the
python right so they are bigger than
anacondas so it's sort of a toss-up the
reticulated python has been clocked as
the heaviest snake in the world because
they get fatter but the anacondas have
been clocked in slightly longer I think
26 feet is the longest ever recorded did
you ever see the Jennifer Lopez movie
yeah the documentary yeah
um yeah it's great it's such a corny
movie it's so good the bad like snake
head if you watch it so bad that's so
bad that's so bad but that was always
the rumor is that there was enormous
snakes in the Amazon and that you know
you just didn't see him I I do believe
that there are some megafauna out there
that are yet to be found that are in low
population like you believe in the sloth
the Giants I believe that has a and
again that's like the thylacine it's a
proven animal it's been 10 000 years but
it doesn't mean that it couldn't be
extant in certain remote areas same with
some of these big snakes maybe not 50
because maybe these things are
embellished but maybe 30 maybe 35 right
and I just think that there are a few
not a lot of these big things out there
if you're one of these uncontacted
Amazonian tribes of which there are
still several pop west Pop wind tribes
whatever
and you're seeing a 50-foot snake nobody
in the Western World we're not hearing
about that right you know like those
things can be happening and those
stories get embellished and passed on
and all of that but we wouldn't even
know until Western science gets in there
and it's sort of a double-edged sword
because once it does it sort of ruins
certain aspects of that right so but I
do believe that there are big animals to
be found still